se nos pide utilizar el menú desplegable
para formar una ecuación lineal con una
infinidad de soluciones una cocción
lineal con un número infinito de
soluciones esencialmente tiene lo mismo
de los dos lados de la ecuación no
importa cuál sea el valor de x que
escojamos para resolverla y lo primero
que quiero hacer es simplificar un poco
el lado izquierdo y luego ingeniar qué
hay que hacer para que el lado derecho
quede igual que el lado izquierdo si
distribuimos este 4 entre x menos 2
tenemos 4 x menos 8 y le sumamos esta
equis y esto va a ser igual a 5 x más
algo y aquí dejo un espacio en blanco lo
que tengo que hacer es escoger el número
correcto para este espacio en blanco
entonces de este lado tengo que 4 x + x
es igual a 5 x menos 8 y del lado
derecho tengo 5 x más espacio y que
ponemos en este espacio para que esto
sea verdadero para cualquier valor de x
aquí tenemos 5 x menos 8 y del lado
derecho tenemos 5
y si ponemos 8 negativo haremos que esto
sea verdadero para cualquier valor de x
que escojamos así que vamos a escribir
menos 8 para cualquier valor de x que
multiplicamos por 5 y le restamos 8 el
resultado será igual a ese valor de x
multiplicado por 5 y restar de 8 y si
quisieran resolver esto restando 5x de
los dos lados de la ecuación
obtendríamos que 8 negativo es igual a 8
negativo lo que es totalmente verdadero
para cualquier valor de x así que vamos
a completar este ejercicio
y hacemos 5 x + 8 negativo